la cámara de los comunes está centrada
en una cosa el futuro de boris johnson
las próximas horas para el primer
ministro serán cruciales y mientras
intenta capear la oleada de críticas en
su contra sigue asegurando que no
renunciará entonces dado que reconoce
que el código ministerial se aplica a
usted renunciará ahora
no señor portavoz en medio de los
reclamos de la oposición laborista
johnson tras la filtración ante el
conocido como pari kate y la
investigación de la policía
metropolitana el dirigente ha intentado
desviar la atención y centrarse en la
crisis de ucrania
y no abriremos esa brecha aceptando a
anular el orden de seguridad europeo
porque rusia haya puesto una pistola en
la cabeza de ucrania tampoco podemos
aceptar la doctrina implícita en las
propuestas de rusas de que todos los
estados son soberanos pero algunos lo
son más que otros el software sam como
sobran donados el gabinete de johnson no
planea tirar la toalla y ya ha asegurado
que hay temas más importantes como el
aumento de la inflación o los conflictos
internacionales aunque parte de la
población no lo ve del mismo modo
eso fue definitivamente en contra de
todo lo que intentábamos a hacer como
nación y se ha infringido la ley
entonces adiós debería irse porque nadie
debería estar por encima de la ley ni
siquiera el primer ministro y vendiendo
realmente entre los que le han dado la
espalda johnson hay muchos diputados de
su propio partido que podrían presentar
una carta de desconfianza para acabar
con la carrera del mandatario